I'm still alive
God damn it!
God bless you Mr.Beast (he moisturises)
God bless your soul (angelic music plays)
You know what it looked like all hope was lost.
Everyone was tweeting,
''PewDiePie is about to get taken over.''
''PewDiePie,''
All the mass media is just celebrating
''Yes!''
''This Indian company,''
Anything except Pewdiepie, basically.
But Mr.Beast (a.k.a our champion)
You saved my life
I owe you my life, thank you.
Mr. Beast: I bought a bunch of billboards,
Ah, dude, we got the double billboard.
We don't mess around
Went on T.V,
Grab your phone, go on youtube, search Pewdiepie,
And subscribe to him.
Did radio ads,
[Mr. Beast on radio] No one kills memes (uh yes they do)
as quickly and efficiently as this Swedish man. (Not a good thing to kill memes)
I hope they haven't passed me when this video goes up.
I have one final thing, though.
I have one last resort.
That I have not used yet, okay?
Because I haven't had to use it, yet.
[Pewds reads] An Indian channel
will soon overtake Pewdiepie to become the most subscribed on YouTube.
You're saying a million dollar company which has thousands of employees
which releases 5-10 videos a day
have their ads everywhere only followed by people who understand Hindi
is up against a self-made guy
who came at this point *( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)*
by starting making videos at home
Has been No.1 youtuber for 5 to 6 years
has following from all around the world
puts...eh..a lot of effort
Ok, that's a bit of a stretch
And even many of them gets copyright strike
That is not a stretch!
He doesn't care; will be making videos for his fans
And will always be No.1 to his fans (That comment forgot to put "Poods makes original content for everyone.")
👏 That is 👏 so sweet 👏
It's interesting how many people just hate me so much
that they'll literally celebrate anyone
taking over.
Bunch of cry-babies (True)
Well you can keep crying for a few more days
(awakens devil-form) CaUsE We'Re sTilL in iT!
Mr. Beast impact
Yeah, it was crazy
Honestly
What do I have now?
I almost have 60...*skrattar*
👏*claps*👏
Its working
When all hope thought it was lost (who the freck is hope?)
It's like in "Lord of the Rings"
When that part happens, you know? (???)
You know what I mean, come on.
Pentagon. Hexagon.
Octagon. A L L  R E V E N U E  G O N E.
What can I say?
I've learned from my mistakes because of my moral code
And no other reasons
Look at this. You guys are really trying hard now
Aren't you?
Posting this again just reminded that
we are winning the ENTIRE war
Because..eh..T-series barely have any followers on Twitter
I don't get it though
the whole thing is so confusing to me.
"You may have won the battle, but not the war."
They haven't won YET!!
Errrrrr!!!
"Working with SpaceX and Tesla"
"Hosting Meme review with Pewdiepie"
👏
COME ON ELON!! We need your help!
Please Elon Musk, please! (we beg you)
ELON MUSK-CHAAAAN
"Stop sending me this sh*t"
So many fake tweets now
I feel like this is fake, too.
People just won't let go.
Hey, look it's another fake tweet
How original!
"Okay fine we'll release Scare Pewdiepie season 2"
"But am I gonna?"
*fax attac*
Oh right it's tana mongoose
I was like, what reference is that
I'm getting old guys. I'm getting too old for memes.
"Imagine writing something and not being able to erase it"
That just gave me a thought, like
What about when you're 8 years old
And some- *Plans malicious plot against T-Series by an innocent giggle*
someone throws, you know cuz' memes
are all about being obscure, and people not really getting it.
You're 80 and someone hits you up with a Uganda Knuckles
and just one person's like,
Hell yeah. We're trollface.
*drama music plays* Trollface. The ancient relic. The ancient symbol
of...
trolling Libtards.
*laughs* Back in my day
"Imagine writing something and not being able to erase it."
This post was made by Pencil Gang.
Pencil Gang is also sponsoring this video (That includes your pencil)
Thank you very much Pencil Gang.
Pencil Gang has decided to join our cause against T-Series
???? Pencil Gang (lolwut)
"Felix, do you think your thoughts in English or in Swedish?"
I don't know. *laughs*
Did you ever think what your thoughts are?
No, I don't think about it.
Probably English.
Sometimes, I speak a lot during my sleep and Marzia's who says I speak in Swedish.
So... I guess there's a, there's a part of Swedish, part of me still in there.
Kicking and screaming
He bought every billboard in my city for this.
*laughs*
Okay, uh- I, if you haven't watched the video, you get it yet.
Check it out, link in the description.
God bless you Mr. Beast.
Now if anyone else will stand up
If any other YouTubers will stand up, in this fight
Which side of war will you be on History...
Channel.
"Here's something I made for Pewds, I hope you- you fellow 9 year olds like it!"
That is pretty epic!
..I must say (lower down your volume if you're using headphones)
except they never accepted my CHALLENGE!!
You have no idea what my twitter feed is right now.
You don't even wanna know.
Dad: Why the eff (f) you crying so damn loud
So proud of Marzia for taking a big step today and following her heart.
Goodbye YouTube.
👏👏
👏
👏 can 👏 we 👏 get a👏..... F👏 in the👏 chat
*laughs*
You know she could've given me the channel, atleast.
So I could be T-Series but you know I guess I gotta be supportive.
Felix, don't forget to make the video that is 5 minutes slowed down 2x to make it 10 minutes.
Why make it 5 minutes when I can make a 10 minute video
20 MINUTES.
I wonder if I get more watch time that way.
Could that be like a wait because YouTube is all about watch time.
The more watch time you have the better.
So maybe if I do that...
Let's do it on this video.
Pewds: Meme review, when?
Elon Musk: Midnight
👏 👏
Hey a tweet that isn't actually fake.
How about that
I'm still waiting Elon.
WE NEED YOUR HELP ELON.
~Tasukete Elon Chaaan~
I know he knows what that means.
A goddamn weeb.
I've seen hus videos David we will be going to therap- what?
What's a PewDiePie and why did you tell your grandpa to subscribe to him?
I'm doing my part.
👏
When you realize PewDiePie won't be the first YouTuber to hit 69 million subscribers.
Come on guys. We have a goal.
We have a mission.
Please.
It's the only thing i'll ever ask you guys for
except constantly asking begging for life subscribers
and all that.
Well please guys it's the only time I ever asked for anything.
I could buy YouTube, delete T-Ser-
This is where the good ideas comes
Release Scare PewDiePie Season 2
BUT AM I GONNA?
DEM.
We were so close
I almost thought this tweet was real.
Incredible.
I was planning to make a video where I rate other people's apologies.
DO IT!
I already did it! Check it out. It was pretty epic.
I wish I could've brought in more apology videos.
They just took so long I don't know why
Well, I got married in a PewDiePie shirt today.
(LOOK AT DIS DUDE)
Look at that, you- you're virgins.
Congratulations
Even 9 year olds can manage to find a... A love for their lives.
Ehh all you gotta do is really buy the merch
I've been saying this for so long.
*laughs*
That's honestly amazing, thank you very much, im honored.
Tha- (wut)
Honestly though, the meme review merch was that 👏👏 The most supported merch of all that i've ever done.
and I just want to say thank you very much for eh... For everyone that got it
I really really appreciate it.
Felix has to get married in a shirt of you now.
Just wear the damn child Felix.
Just marry my wife Felix. *What the F-*
Okay, moving ON
He protec
He attac
But most importantly he is the best. Happy birthday Felix.
This is so sweet.
Except it's not my birthday anymore. You idiot. (oof)
Logan Paul: Pretended to be color blind and faked reaction to seeing colors, tased dead rats, and made fun of a real dead body
Given a high budget sequel to his YouTube movie.
PewDiePie: made 1 joke
Well
It wasn't really one joke
Let's get real here, yes (idk what to call that laugh)
(cute voice but idk what poods is talking)
Yeah it was one, it was one joke, it was one joke.
and had his show cancelled because someone called him
it's okay because he's vegan now
That's true.
Petition for Felix to make a cardboard Elon, so he will actually co-host meme review.
*high pitch voice from poods* Pretty good idea. Thank you.
Elon Musk
Dr. Phil
Ben Shapiro
Being ready to host meme review.
Come up. Come up.
Bring it
Anyone.
So proud of Marzia for taking a big step today and following her heart.
I hope Marzia finds what she's looking for in life and I wish her good luck for the future.
Also, I hope T-Series releases a similar video soon.
One can only dream.
Images you can hear
~Everyone~
~We have an announcement today.~
~Stoooop bullying~
I want him to do a part 2
Like, all of them.
I tried to reach out to the kid
he wouldn't reply
But I know he commented on one of my videos
I know you're listening.
Please. Get all your friends
I beg you
Get all your friends and do
~Everyone~
~We have an announcement today~
👏 👏
MEME
REVIEWWW
Okay. That would be epic. (it already is epic)
PewDiePie fans that are still not in the Subreddit
WHEN WILL YOU SAY HONESTLY THAT YOU'RE DOING YOUR PART.
You can't look at afterwards.
And go, oh I wish things were different. Okay?
You can't pull a Swede and be like, oh sorry Mr. Hitler Summer.
Please go ("country up" *I think that's what he said*)
Ah we should've done something.
You can't do that.
This is not it.
That is it.
That looks like me.
Is that the.. Incredibles kid?
Tim. I wasn't right I was right!
Getting an F in test.
Realizing teachers were just trying to pay respect (See the 2 "to's"? right after the to.)
This is showed. Nice.
YouTube, can you give me money to pay for rent?
To pay for rent?
Yeeeeeees.
Actually buys a useless belt like a boss.
I still have the belt
If anyone can let me know how to use it
That would be great.
Thank you.
Problems of the rich people huh.
This is what i've been saying all along.
Yeah. The more money the more (idk what he said)
*laughs* ( I like the chef that says mama mia )
*LAUGHS*
Nothing hits me like an Italian (pasterie? pastry? IDKWHATHESAID)
Mama mia
Pizzeria
Not even there, she, might see ya. (NICE RHYME)
Imagine having to click to subscribe.
This post was made by T-Series gang.
OOOOOOOOOoooOOoOOooOOOoOHHH
The Last Supper.
yep.
Hello imputes, and i'm here to talk about serious topics
Okay, that's amazing.
skulldino or- did you make this?
I gotta make sure.. Yeah it is
Oh damn he's made a lot of that. Damn that's awesome.
Thank you very much that's really cool.
Yeah, I don't even know what my channel is anymore.
PewDiePie candies
Simple chocolate candy
Can U do this
Lemon candy in green wrapper. Okay.
PewDiePie claps
Oh my God!
You Laugh You Lose cookies
You Eat, You Lose.
This is such good ideas.
Normal
2x baby, oh yeah!
Hope you guys enjoy this video in 2x. You can switch that off now if you feel like it.
Smash like if you enjoy this video
JUST KIDDING!
SUBSCRIBE!
SUBSCRIBE GODDAMMIT
This is our last chance
Listen up you STUPID KIDS. I had enough of you, okay.
I'm not gonna pretend I like you
Because I know
I care about one thing, and one thing only.
DUDE, GET TO 69 MILLION, BEFORE THAT GODDAMN
*LAUGHS*
You know what, it doesn't matter. YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO
There will be no EPIC BROFIST. That's right. I'm retracting all the BROFISTS.
Until this deed is done.
Now you have a true incentive.
Now you have a true challenge.
Now you have something to do with a burning passion
To truly fight for it. That go FORTH DAMMIT.
WHAT ARE YOU STILL DOING HERE
GET THE FREAK OUT
Bye. *LAUGHS*
Subtitles by IAmClueless and Crypticspex
Hi
ANOTHER ORIGINAL CONTENT TO ENJOY RIGHT?
Have a nice day y'all
I think poods should bring back the good ol' brofist outro. Don't you think?
It's about almost 2:15 in the morning I finished the subtitles XD
Now you can leave in peace.
ⓋⒾⒹⒺⓄ ⒹⓄⓃⒺ.